just cow and michael malice thank you
for coming and I apologized but I'll do
it on the air - yeah I've misunderstood
Travis I thought you were just checked
in downstairs I don't realize you were
waiting like I got the seed Big Freedia
some way what's Big Freedia she's the
queen bee but you already know that he
said what's big she's the queen of
Bounce right next door there I seriously
took a photo and put up my Instagram I
don't like the Dave Jessica I just
assumed she was doing shade 45 oh yeah I
just why she races oh did she do know
from Jersey did she do shade 45 yes so
Mike you the host of your welcome every
Wednesday at 2:30 on compound media with
our friend Anthony yeah oh man Rd now oh
yeah Artie that's right they are
co-workers now me and Artie Lange
perfect right well you're probably there
until they get there if you're on a 2:39
hardy for the first time yesterday was
weird cuz when I was in high school I
used to watch it all the time you know
and Stern and I said I just tweet us at
ago if you went back in high school and
told me one day mean our language
coworkers they'd be like wait black
president so what did you show about
it's just me just the talk show just
mean bringing on like fun interesting
guests every week I do a lot of politics
and a lot of well I think politics is my
biggest one well you're able to do also
you do politics you know you're an
entertaining guy but you can do politics
seriously like you do talk are all the
time and stuff yeah because I made my
North Korea background and I'm writing a
new book on the new right which comes
out in April I like when you do Tucker
because you have your serious face yeah
Tucker like I can tell that you're like
you have a serious face and like you're
like we're not smiling this will remind
me not to crack any jokes I'm here as an
expert on North Korea like the jokes but
there I was born in the Soviet Union so
the Soviet side comes out yeah and that
would yeah but you don't have any accent
right like when did you move from there
when I was 2 but actually I just had a
job interview at one point they said
where are you from you're obviously not
from New York and I literally said
connect hers I said [ __ ] map
throw a monitor out the window he goes
you sound like you're from the Midwest I
the job tell you born in Russia I I did
but I was shocked that he said I talk
like a newscaster yeah which I don't
think you don't have a heavy accent
that's a good point newscaster a very
neutral accent you don't have you
actually they have a specific accent
they talk in this mid-atlantic accent
which is kind of from the 40s which I
don't I hate that voice I think it makes
everyone comfortable they think yeah
it's just effective vacation neutral
yeah yeah yeah but your voice is
location neutral I I mean maybe it
doesn't have that like anchoring vibe to
it but it is it is there there's no
specific regional dialect to it I can
talk like Soviet if necessary I
modern-day Dan Soder
[Laughter]
hey have you been North Korea my have I
how many times just watch just watch
this plenty how long really for a week
yeah it's not your vacation spot
it was my vacation spot because then
whenever you go to a party you've got
party cred you've never been you Milan
how long ago were you there this was in
2012 did they have the train that rides
around town playing that song in the
morning do you have the loud speakers
blasting whatever it is the way off
again to song yeah let's get their
wake-up call that's like 7:00 a.m. or 6
a.m. or something yeah it but we were so
when you're there you're a hotel that
they nicknamed the Alcatraz of fun
because it's on an island in the middle
of the river in Pyongyang and you're not
allowed to leave so yeah we didn't
really hear the morning wake-up call ah
so wait was that Kim Jong Il oh it was
owned in charge but Kim Jang hoon was in
charge by at that point yeah oh he was
Kim jong-il died in 2011 okay
so you stay in this hotel everything's
guided I know in North Korea like you
literally everywhere you go there's
people with you and you're not allowed
to see that's not that sounds more
ominous than it is because you can go in
a guided tour of London or New York and
then that wouldn't be weird but if you
can't do anything but guy to direct
North Korea guides and they watch each
other so if you were like I'm kind of
just gonna wander off and do my own
thing you're not well no and also the
guys are going to get in real trouble
because their job is to keep an eye on
you but they can't go on your floor cuz
the floors in the hotel is segregated by
nationality really yes so their floor
has no lights they stepped off the
elevator into darkness it was like it's
just terrifying to watch because we have
BBC in our TVs I thinks the reason so
they're not allowed to go there but so
they just go off into
darkness yeah and they just they just go
into a dark area
I'm just wait until the next mono what's
in that voice some kind of Cthulhu
creature but they stepped off that
elevator and they were drinking with us
to like midnight and they were up at
6:00 and I don't know how they do it but
they did it their camp including the
girl she did it she was pounding him
down Wow
so do you wouldn't started to do any
stories by yourself like you weren't
allowed just to go to a supermarket and
grab something in our supermarkets so we
went to a few stores maybe there's like
the bookstore where all the books except
for one or about Kim jong-il on what's
the one the ones about the North Korean
I talked about this in my book the North
Korean Nelson Mandela re in mo who was
killed captive in South Korea for
decades after fighting for the North all
because he's a hero to the supporting
the rights correct the other ones are
real population so that's but that's the
that's the that's the selling point over
there that's the vibe that they are this
sort of this people that have been done
wrong against and that we're all we all
need to support North Korea because
who's we all North Koreans all right
right because well they don't consider
us those North Koreans they Casilla
South Koreans so whenever you're there N
and s in North and South are lower case
because Korea is one country indivisible
it's been it was the first country on
earth the first language spoken on earth
and the south is in a country it's a
region held captive by the US
imperialists so then what all the maps
have won Korea except when you go to the
DMZ which is the border between the two
so the DMZ well let me ask where there
any vibrating women there like or is
there no way they're very very very
chaste right and and in fact the great
leader Kim il-sung he was writing some
there was a book that was being written
and he goes better that the protagonist
fall in love with like an old widow then
a young girl who's had sex because
everyone likes pure water was his quote
so they're very very chaste but they
look at us like animals so for them to
hook up with a white person even if
Chinese would be like that abomination
it would be like you know like being gay
in the 50s really yeah so they are they
allowed to travel to China or no no they
can't travel it so just quickly North
Korea is dedicate to racial purity it's
the most racist
and homogeneous country on earth it's
something they don't talk about they
can't travel anywhere in fact if you're
a diplomat you have to have family who
stays behind so they're hostages so you
don't defect so they have everyone under
total control all the time so when
people talk about it they think it's
like oh they have these wacky leaders
it's so many more layers of oppression
and control than people realize and I
discussed this at length of my book
because they they want to not only have
only North Koreans or Koreans and
according to them in their country yeah
but they want all of them in their
country correct and you can't escape
right it's a giant prison camp so now
this whole thing where they can't be
this irrational like this all the rest
you know that the storming was starting
nuclear war they can't be that stupid to
not understand what they're what the
results will be wreck the thing is if
you guys saw the Incredibles they talk
about how supervillains like to go in
monologues so when you go there and you
buy their books they spell out their
philosophy explicitly and they say look
we're like an anthill against an
elephant the Americans are like
elephants we can't kill the elephant we
could get it to move where we wanted to
and they say if necessary we know how to
treat America and that means slapping
her across the face so they are brazen
in what their strategy is and there
haven't started any war I mean they're
just shooting missiles they haven't
started anything III oh I've said the
same thing to her I think he's not a
complete dope to think that he's gonna
start a real physical conflict and get
away with it of course and look at the
missiles so like if this look there's
two types of bank robbers right there's
the bank robber who goes in the bank and
starts shooting at the ceiling and says
give me your money and the bank robber
goes in the bank and starts shooting up
people now the first one it may be a bad
person but he's not stupid or crazy he
wants to get out of there the second one
is the dangerous one who's a lunatic
right all those missiles are going to
the ocean they're not shooting them with
soul they're not shooting the motoki oh
and I guess they did the minute they
realized they were about to have a dead
American on their ground right it's an
back a medium exactly because you want
the hostage returned safely so you get
the ransom they also I also thought if
they've really wanted to start a war if
they were for real they would just plow
through the DMZ because they could do
that they could run right over there's
28,000 soldiers well there's a lot of
minds but the thing is it's the most
mined border on earth however those
missiles can hit Seoul what's like
atomic toys at 20 miles south five miles
south and how many people live in salt
can you imagine if forget nukes how many
a city of skyscrapers getting hit by
missiles the visuals of that is
Independence Day so what is the what is
the goal then here
the goal in their part the goal is to
maintain the regime in power and the
goal is to humiliate the US imperialists
at all costs and once they have nukes
they're gonna be pretty impenetrable and
Kim jong-il said the father of Kim
jong-un said it to fight the Chinese
dragon and the Russian bear and the
American Eagle I have to turn our
country into a hedgehog by which he
meant missiles pointing in every
direction and no one can attack a head
talking about how big they are okay
because there's missiles it
yeah like the spines of a hedge so
they're like oh so he's like he's like I
know we can't win right but we can do a
lot of damage on the way out right and
oh yeah yeah if and when when so having
Kim jong-il take over for his father Kim
il-sung the founder of North Korea when
against all communist propaganda cuz the
cause of communism everyone's equal the
idea you're gonna hand over the
leadership to your son is crazy right so
they have a backstory to explain this
and there's this big meeting that never
happened where Kim il-sung's with the
general generals it says what if the
u.s. Americans invade what are we gonna
do or kill him over kill him what will
win and he goes with what if we lose and
Kim jong-il says if we lose we will
destroy the world and he goes spoken
like a real true like a true Supreme
Commander and that was his justification
for taking over so their whole premise
is if we're going down we're taking as
many people with us and you can't blame
them right that's the best kind of
threat to make is a threat that you
actually mean can I use as good the
ultimate question though why did you go
there uh-uh how do you even get a flight
there it's it's Li China right it's
legal there's one flight in and out
anyone can go not anymore they just
changed it recently it's because of a
kid because of the kid and I'll cuz of
these nuclear escalations right I went
because being born the Soviet Union
being born being Jewish those are two
chances someone in my family could have
been a concentration camp and they have
camps right now that you can see in
Google Earth where they take whole
families so I'm like I want to see what
my family went through you know seventy
years were you able to get near those
camps prior nervous you wouldn't be able
to return I was nervous until I it's I
was not nervous once I was there I was
nervous before I got there cuz if they
found out who I was or what I was doing
you know doing research for a book that
would be a big problem but I got through
so when you when you think that this
whole honor otto warmbier yeah one beer
uh do you think he actually took that
because there's a black-and-white photo
he did take it he
tried to take it so not only did he try
to take it he tried to he was
trespassing
so before I went you know you do your
homework online and there's a secret
floor in the hotel that you're not
allowed to go now if you go to the White
House the Fitz floor yeah it's like the
fourth and a half all right so if you
you go to the White House and you start
trespassing you steal Hillary Clinton's
portrait that Secret Service isn't gonna
wag your finger at you sure so you can't
go to the North Korean guards and give
them the finger and expect not to have
consequence that wasn't the White House
this is a hotel right yeah but it's it's
effectively everything everything is the
White House and you're dealing with
murderers who have no respect for their
own people why would they respect you so
he was playing a very dangerous game and
it's it's disgusting and tragic but he
paid the consequences so you have to
understand when you're going there right
that every building you go to is the
White House and and these people are
monsters right who chose to allow one to
two million of their population to
starve in the 90s rather than let go of
their hold of power so why did it why
did he just did it to get something cool
to bring Jack was another souvenir he
could have got exactly I mean it take
the risk because if he gotten the photo
he would have been no the flag he's
trying to steal a banner right no
there's I think it was a picture with
one of the leaders on it which the the
iconography of the leaders there is
regardless holy and then he would have
been like a living legend here like it
would have been a classic a legendary
photo to have a reason for right here we
wouldn't look at a picture of a leader
like with any kind of holy religious
context you'd be like who cares it's
just a photo of that guy you could look
it up online exactly right and they're
like they have they tell these stories
and newspapers of someone having a fire
and they run in and they saved this two
portraits and they themselves die and
this is regarded as virtuous and it's
like we can't wrap our heads around this
mentality yeah because you can like in
are why wouldn't you get another picture
right and everyone in the everyone North
Korea has these two pictures on their
walls so so why would you get what I
know name I know it doesn't make sense
but they buy it but they do and you're I
do the people buy it or are they so
shook that they're just like okay
whatever whatever you said the people
are decreasing Lee buying it the young
people as more and more information as
are going in or like wait a minute maybe
Kim il-sung couldn't literally walk on
water and turn leaves into bullets how
is the information starting to leak turn
leaves into bullets they really believe
that [ __ ] oh yeah
and I'm more surprised by the walking in
water than leads into bullets that's
MacGyver we have the guys walk on water
so I mean they they so but the thing is
it's like in America you have people in
the countryside the rural areas who are
more credulous and people in the cities
who think they're sophisticates and
especially because as people are
defecting and they have like memory
sticks they're getting from China
they're learning about the outside all
right the memories yeah and that is
there has to be a way for some people to
get some internet access there has to be
people smart enough to figure that out
but they don't electricity how you're
gonna have an index no no no so if
there's this very famous picture of the
Korean Peninsula at night and South
Korea is lit up like a Christmas tree in
the North is just one spot which is
Pyongyang so people think you go to the
capital city Pyongyang and it's so
beautiful and it's a lie to you it's not
beautiful everywhere you go there's a
crack every play every single place has
a smell every place had a fly including
the plane the carpets are all stained
and there's Central Park there's this
fountain that wasn't running and it's
covered in mildew so you can't escape
the corruption decay and even the
capital city at night they don't have
most electricity so really yeah I don't
know I didn't realize they had no
electrician it's not no but at the cap
it's for the most the country it snow at
night and and in the capital it's like
let's say 70% so after you get back from
going there yeah do you feel like okay I
got what I not only just research for
your book but like you said like I want
to go and see what what my relatives had
to had to deal with back then like did
you get a sense of it a better sense of
it yeah and it was funny because I
showed the porch photos of North Korea
to my friend and he's like this looks
like Russia but it's Asian people
wearing Russian clothes in Russian
buildings it was like at all the
mindfuck for him
the biggest thing that I took away which
drives me crazy this day is every single
person I met there every kid every woman
on the street that I waved to every
single one is still there so that really
[ __ ] with your head yeah like think
about everything you've been doing for
the last five years they're still
trapped there and there's nothing
they're gonna do about and or all your
photos approved oh no they don't care
the guides are savvy like and the thing
is the company that you work with they
can pick which guide they want so
there's some guys who are guides who are
like kind of hip with the program and
the ones who are really into the
propaganda they don't work with so let
me know do they check your file would
always be scared to go they look on your
they could look on your phone if they
wanted to if they think
phone they'd like at the at the airport
so you only had your camera Wow oh you
don't have a phone no they took it so
did you have like a digital camera yeah
yeah do you get it back when you leave
yeah at the airport Wow they kept track
of it the whole time like oh yeah I'd be
so worried I'd be like I gave it to you
five days ago you must have a ton of
cell phone if something had done of cell
phone onto your phone or anything no no
no I don't think they did oh yeah right
maybe there's a tracking device on it or
something well I got a metro pcs I don't
know about that they took your phone at
the airport yeah weird thing to say
we're taking the phone it's not weird
because they don't want you contacting
the outside world yeah that'd be the way
to do it what yeah no I know I know why
they do
papow shut your phone off before I
wasn't selling your phone to somebody in
North Korea only then there's a phone
yes in the thing and they slowly start
to lose control that way well they have
phones with each other don't they yeah
but I mean that's very expensive and
it's very it's all I think it's all
monitored they have cell phones there no
yeah but they again it doesn't have
electricity well they have since it's
they don't have you're not calling to
China on your cell phone
it's like local service only it's like
the show the prisoner from the 60s right
so they they keep a pretty tight lid on
it well we go in or no yeah people have
snuck phones in but how are you gonna
sneak a phone if you don't have cell
towers you know what I mean like the you
need a lot of technology and
functionality for that yeah no there's
no need to sneak in because you won't
get into reception right thank you a
satellite phone right do you think
there's any chance that you know the
people will or could uprise I mean at
some point north korea has something
called sessions of daily life and what
that means is everyone in North Korea is
slotted in to like their school or their
neighborhood or their office and once a
week you have to get together and say
like AAA or for example you have to say
what you did wrong and then your
colleagues have to say what they saw you
doing wrong and this has been going on
since the 70s so everyone watches each
other all the time by law and reports on
each other publicly by law so the idea
that you can get together and be like
hey let's take down Kim jong-un is like
it's not gonna happen so they're very so
many stitches every snitching hat by law
so at people talk about how like they're
dumb or crazy it's like this is
brilliant I mean it's a brilliantly
totalitarian dictatorship but they got
it covered
I mean it's evil it's pure evil but it's
it is is it
supervillain yeah it's a mentality when
I was doing writing the book it this was
didn't happen overnight this was a
decade's long process as they closed the
barriers and sealed the country and step
by step you know took over complete
control we heard from it and not that
the communication is terribly easy from
over there but have you heard from
anybody over there about your book do
you know there's no way anyone if anyone
had my book in North Korea they and
their families would be executed
immediately do you know if the
government is the North Korean
government is aware of you or your book
they are but they only go after their
own
so since I'm white and Western I don't
matter to them but you couldn't go back
I could and don't ask me how don't you
love me considered white and Western and
not Jewish isn't that the best how could
you go back oh you'd be tricking them
yes oh okay he's got a mask I I
I was thinking he's already been bad
yeah I was thinking about it then my
friend went I looked at the photos I'm
like I couldn't take it again it [ __ ]
with your head really bad to see them
when you're in the DMZ and you're in
between that building that we have room
is divided you have the north soldiers
in the south soldiers and I guess they
have they know each other on some level
because they look at each other every
day no because they're watching each
other so that well they know of each
other they are communicating you only
they speak at all they can't because the
this guards watch each other right the
northern guards so if my buddy is a
guard and he's look talking to the South
he's a traitor but you think they just
not at each other one oh hell no they're
watching each other to make sure there's
no signs of anything because like you
said that the mentality of the country
is to rat everybody out like he's not
and this is a plum position right so if
you're on the south side and it's split
in the middle like if what happens if
you walk to the north side of them in
the middle the room is not the room you
can walk anywhere you want the room
because they're gonna step over the line
in the room right okay I don't think
there's a line in the room the room is
kind of a neutral oh yeah yeah but if
you walk out that door
oh that you just get a major problems
would you be arrested immediately it's
not shot um
can you walk out that door there garlic
well you go to the South before the
South to go to the north no no for like
if you're as a tour and market tourist
you're in the DMZ and you're in that
room between the two countries if you
walk through the north side or the guard
stop you from walk
through yes even though I'm there as a
tourist of the North yeah no no as a
tourist in the south oh there's no way
they would shoot American tourists if
you walk through them oh yeah they would
love it so in 1970 I think for there
were two Americans who went to chop down
a tree at the DMZ and the northerner why
they do that because it was blocking
their view so the North so American well
the northerners took that axe and
chopped up the Americans the axe is
still on display in the north and they
are regarded as heroes and the Americans
came back with what they called
Operation Paul Bunyan which is like a
huge show of force and they didn't chop
down that tree they left a stump to show
those North Koreans whose boss
operation Paul Bunyan Wow Marvin the
Martian who wanted to blow up the earth
because it blocked his view of being cut
it down yeah I was in the north
the SAP the Americans wanted to see the
north and then chop down this prune the
tree and the northerners chopped them up
but wasn't the tree I was in south or
was it it was in the DMZ in the in the
neutral area oh and they said you didn't
ask for permission and now you know you
know you're dead now you're minced meat
and they boast about using taekwondo
tactics which is that which is the
korean martial art great everything
Koreans great yeah guard inside that
room blocking the access to the north no
I think they're in the coroner's if I
remember correctly but you can't walk
you know walking out that door
you'd be stopped oh yeah yeah there's
guard that's what points a guard that's
the white guards are four in any
building do you I would imagine the
Dennis Rodman's treatment in North Korea
is very very different from yours
I know we were probably both treated
very well but I mean I'm not getting
drunk with Kim Jong Un's they put on a
show for it that's what I mean like they
try to avoid like the fountain that
doesn't run in the cracks everywhere I
mean he is such an abomination and and
and I mean like he should have had a
Dewan beers fate I mean this guy was on
Sunday morning TV and they asked him at
the concentration camps and he literally
said we have prisons what's the
difference so it's like listen buddy if
you're making apologies for someone who
murders children to maintain political
control you are as low as it gets in an
inhuman but is he but Italy ask you this
and just if he's going over there any
has some kind of relationship with the
guy yeah we deal with people who are
scumbags and sure
like like when our politicians they
never speak honestly but they're not
talking about what barbarians China Kim
bu what pieces of [ __ ] this there are so
there's a certain amount of way you talk
about things when you have another goal
not that Dennis Rodman has a higher
motive but I mean if he's got an in with
the guy why [ __ ] it up just to say what
we already know well I get I mean but
Donald Trump's never killed anyone
Hillary Clinton's only killed one person
so there are other countries though the
way like Trump and Hillary or all
politicians will talk about another
country if they're an ally of ours even
if they're pieces of [ __ ] like the
Saudis they don't speak honestly about
the Saudis correct so I mean I don't
really fault Rodman for not trashing a
little fast enjoy not trashing and
having a moral equivalence between
concentration camps and American prisons
but he's done though he's not a bright
guy is with me I'm sorry I think there's
I don't know what he knows that I don't
care I mean I'm in enough of a
eugenicist that if you're that stupid
that maybe we should put you down
I like though I would go over there and
hang out with him if I could when I ate
when I came back and I was like don't
you have a problem with the
concentration camps you'd be like yeah
we're going back though before you like
on your last trip you say that well they
say that you know the UN attacked them
for these camps and their response was
we don't use that term so we don't have
any so sorry and Rodman there's no shot
at getting anything done probably I
don't think he'll be able to change
anything she does have a shot in this
sense that you know when you know
someone another country maybe you have
warmer affection for that country so in
some vague sense in the sense that he's
making America not seem like the villain
yeah 100% in this sort of very small
beginning step right way so they're
taught that we started the Korean War so
did we
today so we didn't think so but you but
you want that's for a few days ago but
you also today yeah that was yes Dennis
Rodman wants to straighten things out
between Donald Trump and North Korea you
never know who people listen to like I
never know what friends influence people
the most like it's really like you know
look at work how many think dumb example
mash was gonna be taken off the air in
its first season but though the wife of
the head of CBS I think I loved it and
would like you never know who someone's
listening to
maybe this [ __ ] ridiculous Rodman
says something that Kim Jong was like
maybe yeah yeah I don't know I mean
seeing our boasting that they go skiing
and don't talk politics I mean this
doesn't sit well with me you don't like
that yeah cuz there is politics to talk
about that might be the only way to do
it is to not do it and then you wait for
him to bring it up it might be the only
way in so you won't try to [ __ ] a hot
girl you can't always be trying to put
your hand on her pants you have to kind
of wait until she indicates and then
she's like oh you just said he's a
stupid man I'm sorry is the least hot
girl on earth number two is I the whole
point of my book it's written the first
person I'm playing devil's advocate I'm
explaining the North Korean point of
view and it's very unlike no one in
North Korea tells this guy anything or
what to do you know I mean he's an
absolute dictator like Kanye West right
so if right sorry if Dennis Rodman is
saying we don't talk politics I think
it's very hard to and the thing is the
moment that he starts to contradict him
and make a problem it's he's gonna get
on up get on a plane to get kicked out
well it may be over but maybe one time
Kim jong-un asked him what do you think
you never know I mean like that's what
I'm saying you don't mention it you wait
for the other person so I'm sure after
after several visits a couple of drinks
kim jeong-hoon is like so seriously rod
all right are the prison camps that bad
and and rodman then has the opportunity
to be like dude you know I love you but
yeah Ravana talks like that guy from the
the Fat Albert gang like you can't
understand anything it's the other one
it's dumb Donald right plus the
translator I'm sure exactly I know but
what are they talking about if he
doesn't speak there's obviously a
translator of some sort I know what
they're talking about they're discussing
whether hotdogs a sandwich and the
answer is no it is probably a nonsense
relationship very surface level it's
like a rush hour reboot except once a
genocide of murderer the Chicago Bulls
yeah the 1990s non-stop probably all I
would want to talk to Dennis Rodman
about to the 90s Chicago Bulls is all
they talk about
a couple of pistons and we was like the
[ __ ] Carmen Electra
do you think though that if he likes a
kim jeong-hoon was gonna start something
for real I wouldn't would it surprise
you if one of his own people just shot
him yes ignore me I I can't even wrap my
head they that cook like or even the
generals who are probably a lot smarter
than he is and understand the
consequences a lot more than he does
right even they're willing to go down
with the ship like that that's why
they're there they're not there because
they're smart or they worked their way
up through the ranks like Chuck Schumer
or Mitch McConnell they're there because
of their loyalty to the regime right so
whenever a new leader took over they
purged the previous people's people
because they said I only want that
people are gonna die for me what does
purge me Mironov get either fire or kill
represent to the country side they're
not always killed sometimes they just
get get a become ambassadors or
sometimes they get some crappy job
somewhere but they know when they're
sent to the countryside you stay on the
country so there's otherwise you're not
allowed to travel in that country on
government permission well what is
travel like meaning like if I so based
okay there's another level of oppression
they have they have something called
some bun which means they sat down in
the 50s and they interviewed everyone in
the country everyone and they do this
every few years and they figured out
where you stood in relation to the
regime and you were slotted into it's
like a credit score into three classes
hostile wavering and and a favorite
class and basically if you are in a
hostile caste you can't go into the
capital city it assigns you where you
live whether you go to college who you
marry so if you are you know anyone in
your family is suspected of not being
loyal to the regime you can't even step
foot in Pyongyang is there movement or
is it a caste system you can you can
move up you're right but it's a lot
easier to move down right but how do you
they arrange the person you're gonna
marry or the class that you're gonna
matter so it's kind of like status here
like if you're from old money you know
you're not gonna marry some lecture some
hillbilly she's not one of us right it's
exactly like that
yeah but how do you even meet girls or
is it all arranged I mean there's a lot
of arrangement parties go on dates
it's big oh it was very cute because my
my guide she was very desperate to speak
good English and her accent was
impeccable and she talked about how the
parks they engage in gentle walking was
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] date
I said the term is strolling I mean this
is her translation and like I felt
really bad because it's like she's been
saying this for years and everyone's
laughing at her no one's corrected her
you gentle walk in you corrected her
yeah I'd be so afraid to correct it no
no no she was so happy she had a little
notebook she's writing down slang so
strolling means that's what she doesn't
know did they go for a walk in the in
the [ __ ] mildewed park park by the
tidal river it's very lovely so you
don't think they [ __ ] before marriage
a lot their [ __ ] in cars they were
slaves Kim jong-il said it's a very bad
thing to have spare time because that
allows people to be selfish and liberal
they want to have every minute of your
day taken care of it's it's so much
noise than people think you say kids
like I mean why would people who kids
why would you want to bring somebody
else into that because that's all you
know and you love someone do they make
them do that no no no they don't make
him have kids I mean but isn't it cruel
to them to procreative in it in a
situation like this what your kids are
gonna grow up to be in this way you're
old enough to remember Ethiopia where
all those people are starving at those
kids with pot bellies right I thought
they're [ __ ] in these camps like
exactly you know I can write I forgot to
put your dick in some baby comes out
that's the white kids exist because you
know there's a reason they made
unprotected sex feel good they they some
people are saying that Rodman's not evil
though that he's just being mischievous
who's saying that someone on the phone I
mean it's probably my I can't speak to
whether he's evil or mischievous I can't
speak I don't know someone said the my
husband your hatred for the people say
mischievious oh no ii I oh there's no
thirstiness yes so they blew they didn't
land the joke you whoever is on that
phone you're pathetic
yeah thank you brainy drink bleach okay
Brady you're on the phone no you're not
so what do you suppose what is the
appropriate response when North Korea is
like we got all these missiles
hey guess what the Pink Ladies back we
got hydrogen bombs
we're gonna blow stuff up what are you
gonna do
when when they had a date where they're
gonna take our Guam and president from
said we're gonna respond with fire and
fury the likes the world's never seen it
was like oh my god you can't talk to
them like that
Guam still here so when you speak to
someone on the same level you guys are
comics right when someone is funny and
you're funny back you see there's a
report there's a certain languages right
someone is being like I'm gonna destroy
the world you're like oh yeah well I'm
gonna destroy twice it's like okay I get
this guy I think Trump might have a bad
rap but I think that there is a guy like
that there is something scary about him
to other people cuz he's unpredictable
and they know he's a loudmouth yes Obama
was a diplomatic guy and they knew that
he was going to be very thoughtful yes
is very careful and Trump they don't go
they don't have that funeral would be
like we're gonna blow up blow up Guam
and he doing please don't or no please
do we don't need it Trump's response was
good on that yeah it worked I mean
absolutely we're also the the Tillerson
came out and said we were having a lot
of behind-the-scenes negotiations with
them so the thing with North Korea's you
can never this drives me crazy because
whenever I see people on TV talking
about North Korean they know what
they're talking about I'm just like shut
shut up it's a complicated subject they
but you can't take anything they do at
face value like if they're just like we
have any that's all lies yeah I remember
2000 what 14 13 there was a photo of Kim
jong-un in front of his Apple Computer
and behind him there was a nuke hitting
Austin and my friends like is he gonna
nuke Austin I'm like if you're gonna
nuke Austin why are you putting it on
Instagram that I'm gonna nuke make me a
Photoshop what this will look like right
before I do it right and what does Trump
say about this we've been paying we do
kind of just pay them blackmail money
just to not act up like what is the
money that we waste giving them that he
was talking about because there's so
much money I think that we put into that
I mean the Clintons had them put a pause
by basically bribing them so North Korea
also they boast about in the propaganda
they go look we're always gonna have you
know harsh language but we'll have a way
out for example a say for example we'll
say we've never been offended like this
is the huge humiliation against the
great nation of Korea however if you
want to give us some oil we'll choose to
forgive you this one time so they're
explicit that this is their strategy but
man Trump's basically saying go [ __ ]
yourself yeah why we praying
mahler if you're still going to be
escalating the tensions if this strategy
is so explicit why do we tend to fall
for it because it's explicit if you go
to Pyongyang and read the books I mean
that many people have done that why
don't they just read your book if it's
in your book why don't they just read
the book it's like oh man let's kind of
cleared this up if people in the media
did more research they wouldn't be in
the media I mean it's it's very sad
especially on this one issue it's my pet
peeve because it's so complicated they
want to compare to Iraq they want to
compare it to Hitler they want to
compare to the Soviet Union it's like
it's its own thing do you think that is
China had kind of enough of this guy
already they've had enough with them for
a while and at the same time they don't
want 25 million refugees storming their
border with who don't speak Chinese
who've never seen a computer they don't
want an American ally on their border so
and at the set at the same point the
same way the same way that North Korea
likes to give us the finger they like to
give China the finger look they're like
look we're the size of Pennsylvania and
our leader makes China and the American
is crazy I mean right they should be
proud of that but do you but the tension
is escalating do you think China be want
to cut them off completely North Korea
they're so smart that earlier this year
he stockpiled a million gallons of oil
and pointed out and their press release
in everyone missed this that this latest
hydrogen bomb whatever it was was made
using homegrown materials by what she
means even if you sanction us and you
make us completely isolate from this the
world we can still continue with this so
China homegrown right so China doesn't
this idea that China can just call him
up and put a stop to this overnight is
ridiculous back to that but just to [ __ ]
with him for just just to just stop any
type of triggers Trump is threatening to
stop any type of trading with any
country who's doing business with them
and that's a major problem if that
happens I agree that's a major problem
but again during the 90s when the famine
hit Kim jong-il said having too many
people make socialism difficult and he
said if the UN feeds them they won't
need the government so he let the people
starve so and then he will say you're
starving because of the US imperialists
right it'll be true right sense so if if
the US if they stopped getting anything
from any other country they'll still
this is they're prepared for that yes
they've set up the psychological and
they said the Americans have wanted to
conquer you since the 1860 and that's
what they're doing here what's the USS
General Sherman in Pyongyang
start the Korean War and listen the
Korean War as bad as it was for us you
have China and Russia in the North you
have the UN Americans in the South
Korea's in the middle war is I mean you
hear these conservatives talk about war
like it's a picnic it's it's the biggest
nightmare ever obviously and the coal
country was decimated how many families
and lives were ruined and they remember
that this wasn't that long ago for them
right and they're being told there the
Americans are waiting to finish the job
and they especially remember it because
like they got nothing else to distract
Yeah right like a little kid remembers
everything because they got nothing in
their brains right if your day is just
mundane and nothing and there's no
information going in your head except
state-run information you're gonna
retain all of it and all you imagine if
all the if every if the only TV show is
mash you'll be thinking about the Korean
War a lot yeah do you think who do you
think is worse kim jeong-hoon or his
father the father was worse because the
father had two million corpses on his
hands okay God who is more delusional
neither of them a delusional anyway know
what's delusional I mean he's in charge
and he runs his country like a tight
ship putting its whether whether you
agree with it right it's what he's doing
his work yeah well I'm saying delusion
was to I guess he maybe he's not
delusional this so he does know what
would happen if he does something yeah
he's like Conor McGregor like on some
level he knows he's not beating Floyd
Mayweather right but he also knows that
the key to people buying this fight and
this happening is just to run his
[ __ ] mouth as well just tries to
target and also to get getting get a gun
nukes yeah yeah if Conor McGregor had a
gun in that fight he would have won it's
fair to say so what happens if we we hit
there are certain installations we got
to make sure we take out everything at
once or else it's gonna get really bad
really ugly and they're they are
prepared to retaliate immediately and
hit Seoul and they would hit snow they
wouldn't fund I always think something
like this actually brings every but like
if China and the US and all the feels
like it'll bring everybody together now
I have this common enemy Nodin is really
glad that this is [ __ ] with us really
oh yeah he's just what everybody would
be on board what is this kumbaya Brady
Bunch [ __ ] this is geopolitics everyone
hates each other yeah they they like it
when they're at their rivals get hurt
yes princess and Craig cart right now
that's princess happy the crazy mericans
are getting stressed out by North Korea
as Putin going like these stupid
America's Russia that's funny
could we don't give a [ __ ] about the
Chechens we never think about them no
they can't get their [ __ ] together
they're awesome theater the comics come
up with the Watchmen oh you know when
they had that they thought they had the
threat from space and then everybody got
together I guess that's what I'm hoping
no because it's also like honestly like
you said it's the size of Pennsylvania
the idea that the whole world would have
to get together to fight this one little
place is like ridiculous and it
completely buys into everything they're
selling the word is world power right
that it takes the entire world to stop
us as opposed to so how is we face at
all I mean I mean they thought yeah he
can't walk on water but he can say with
a straight face
I have the entire world and pissing
their pants and he he knows that he
can't walk in water so the idea that
he's being portrayed as delusional goes
to this way of thinking that well he
wrote that so he must think it's truly
as opposed to it's propaganda what do
people who write the propaganda know
what it is and you know what else I
promise you George Washington never
chopped down the cherry tree and there
was no cherry tree ever
yeah we tell stories of our country nice
driving so we'll use their you're only
allowed to take pictures of like
monuments and stuff like that everyone
oh you can yeah yeah yeah the only big
one is there's a like I think it's like
eight stories high statue if you go to
my website there's a great picture of me
with the 2-litre statue it's like eight
stories high and when you take a photo
of them you can't crop it you have to
have their full body I don't know never
says why but yeah they don't know about
post you just put on your phone and crop
it later no no there's that textured
shift oh yeah you're allowed to be in
the picture yes but they don't know that
like if you just put in a Photoshop you
could just crop it anything they do know
but is they're not gonna see that yeah
yeah they're like look if you do
whatever you're gonna do at home right
like it being in a relationship where
you're like just don't humiliate me
don't let me find out right do what you
got it you're on the road do what you
got to do it's very Victorian ya Ask
Don't Tell is an eight-story so I by the
way see you
Don't Tell is there any day life there
do you think or no I saw this great
documentary and there it was it was with
this Canadian reporter and he's with his
guides at the ostrich ranch in Pyongyang
and there by the ostriches with the odd
just up the actual birds okay
yeah because if chickens can feed people
ostriches can feed more people was the
logic yeah so he's talking the guys this
is the second trip and he goes we talked
about gays and lesbians before they go
yes yes yes we don't have that here he
goes
what about bisexuals and they guys the
guide sighs he's like what guys look I
already got down with this whole sodomy
thing you guys do like I don't need to
know any more about this stuff but the
middle son so Kim jong-il had three sons
Kim jong-un is the youngest the middle
son is gay it is like a girl and too
much of a [ __ ] to really alterus the
car yes yes is he still there no he's a
Eric Clapton groupie and tours the world
yes does he have money
oh yeah but the Elvis Huey the eldest
son Kim jong-nam was the one who's
recently killed that was no that was the
the the thing of the airport yes girl
what do you think did that was that kim
jong hoon 100% because according to the
ten commandments of North Korea the
tenth commandment is the revolution
shall be continued through the
generations until it's complete which
means only a direct descendant of Kim
il-sung can be the leader
so if Kim jong-nam is dead there's no
plan B for Kim jong-il stakin out if
what about the other brother they're not
letting hit yeah I mean he doesn't
actually isn't even acknowledges what is
to see his brother if who went to see
these what's this is one III got his
name but he he clap tonight yeah I I
don't know I I think it wouldn't end
well for him is that him really they
killed him jangling one boy brother and
he was a blood relative yes why did they
kill him a half-brother so are we a
descendant of Kim il-sung can be the
leader right oh it was a half-brother
right so if there's two and he was
passed over so if there's two brothers
and one is killed you have to stick with
kim jungeun
right I asked him over what's that who
passed on this is the end of my book Kim
Jong Il passed
because he wanted to liberalize he
wanted to denuclearize and he wanted to
have it like a Chinese process and Kim
jong-il said if you want openness open a
window
we're Koreans it won't work for us yeah
is that great but Kim jong-il didn't
punish him for saying that he just
passed him over well I mean it's a big
punishment you're gonna be the leader of
a country now you have to live on the
lam know how but I mean did he throw him
out of the country or he decided to
leave I think it was more he was in fear
for his life
correct probably for a good reason
obviously he got yelled yeah well that
makes sense because now that is that Kim
Jong Il's solidifying the fact that he's
going to remain the leader yeah correct
Kim Jong Un's yes correct
where did where did he get he wasn't in
North Korea when he got good was he yeah
Wow he lived in Macao it was genius how
they got there how they got them to do
it they got this
they told those girls was a [ __ ] joke
Frank is putting a towel over someone's
face that's not a press they lose face
no is a towel it's a good outer but it's
still it's I mean you saw the video it's
not it's not a prank
Frank is like you know I don't know okay
my mind's going to dark places yeah my
turn yes